so my opinion on short films
um look I think that people get to a
place where they just keep on doing
short films and all they do is short
films and they sh they they they feel
like ah this is all I can afford to do
right now but what they don't realize is
that once you've done like
three short films I want to say maybe
even four that's enough short films
let's if you want to do a feature it's
time to move on to a feature because
here's what I think like literally one
short film if you're not dealing with a
lot of money maybe you're doing it
yourself it takes like six months I want
to say to make a short film right
if you just took the time and energy and
maybe even save it the money or got
other people to come in with you
spend a year and do a feature because
then you're in the club then you can you
know when you go to the festivals you
see how they treat you when you're a
short film and then you'll see how they
treat you when you're a narrative
feature narrative you get more respect
that way plus I said you're in the club
people think you can be trusted to now
do another you know narrative feature
right if it's good I mean hopefully it's
good if it's not good I can't help you
but if it's good then you're in the club
like I said they trust you you can
probably find some investors it's it's
such a you know achievement to finish
like a a a a full narrative feature I
mean it literally it literally puts you
in another League
um so I would tell you to to if you've
done three shorts Four Shorts Max don't
do any more shorts the other advice I
have for shorts if you're making a short
keep it short people try to make these
30 minute shorts and I'm like who's
gonna program you okay when you're
thinking about phone festivals they're
trying to fit in like you know five to
ten shorts in a short section now your
30 minute short took up like three
positions good luck on them good luck
good luck on them programming you let
alone uh you know any of the festivals
programming let's just the most magical
short that they can't live without but
nine times out of ten it's not so if
you're doing a short make it short
what if someone spends 300 000 on a
feature film and they never finish it
that's not good
because that shows that
um I mean look a lot of things can
happen your actor dies I don't know but
beyond something like that you should
finish the movie you went to yourself
you went to the investors uh uh you
ought to everyone who worked on that
movie to finish the film
um
you know I I know there are a whole
bunch of reasons why people don't but if
you don't then maybe you're not meant to
be a filmmaker
maybe because you don't you shouldn't be
wasting anyone else's money if you
haven't finished the first one unless
someone died that's understandable but
you know beyond that if you just didn't
finish it because you lost your passion
or whatever you better find your passion
because someone's money is out there
wouldn't you say that for a majority of
first-time filmmakers they should try a
a short first not a feature
I think look if you're trying to find
your tribe A lot of times right like
some people go to film school and they
find their tribe over there and they
have the set sort of people that are
going to work with them the rest of
their lives if you are some person
living in the Heartland who was never
made a movie before and you've been
reading a lot about it and watching a
lot of YouTube videos well you better
start finding local people in your kind
of neck of the woods that want to help
you and that you want to help as well in
turn because you got to find your tribe
you got to literally go to the local
theater Department start talking to them
start figuring out can I get some actors
who might want to be in my movie for
free because maybe they do want to be in
your movie for free
um you have to find the people that are
going to help you become the filmmaker
that you will become you need a tribe to
do that so you need to go and figure out
who those people are and start working
with them and start like you know
becoming bessies with them right I mean
um
I I that's a it's a I can't stress that
enough like it's it's very important to
be around like-minded people right
um and in now the world is much smaller
you can find these people online you
know I mean I I remember when I was
doing my Festival run I was we're trying
to get into festivals I was so
frustrated I couldn't figure out like
all these festivals are so secretive I
started a Reddit group talking about
like we would all talk about film
festival rejections and who we got into
oh that one's releasing uh they're
they're releasing uh they're saying yes
to people over here already we became a
community in this microcosm we became a
community and that's that threat is
still going on Reddit to this day it's
like five years old or something but I
mean just online I found people right
who were going through the same as
me
um and to have the same frustrations and
whatever else you can do that online you
can get suggestions you can find mentors
you can people are willing to help if
you if you reach out to them and ask
them questions I'll give you some time
they can't give you all the time but
they'll give you they'll give you
something right and then again your
local community you have to find your
live if you want to make a movie because
it's not just you and to your question
should you show up to your shorts sure
start off doing shorts but don't just
stuck into shorts because it's sooner
and sooner or later it's not as hard as
you think to make a movie for all the
time you were putting into this short
you could take a year and probably make
a movie now it may take you two years to
make a movie if you're doing it off and
on or whatever else that's fine too
and I would tell you this like look
you're going to have a lot of people who
doubt you right you may have a parent or
an uncle or a cousin it's always making
fun of you oh that's crazy Charlie he's
making his movie whatever those
people you have to do what you have to
do okay you have your crew you have your
your team and you're gonna keep on
making them even if it takes you two
years to make that movie and hell it may
not be a good movie this time right but
you're gonna learn a hell of a lot
you're going to learn a hell of a lot
and hopefully you'll get in somewhere
hopefully have a little Premiere or
whatever else and people can feel
validated people feel more validated
when you're making a movie outside of
California they want to help you they
want to see like they want to see you
succeed a lot of times they'll let you
have the diner for free at two o'clock
in the morning as long as you don't burn
it down right they'll help you
um you just got to put yourself out
there and have a good crew and and and
don't stop trying to make the movies
like I mean if you that's in your heart
you have to do it you have to do it you
should do it absolutely
so many people have a romantic notion
about filmmaking wouldn't it be better
that they try their hand at several
short films before jumping into the
feature Club
I mean like I said I I think that's fine
um you know a lot of people if they're
you know going to film school or taking
any film classes that are they get they
get their feet wet a little bit with
some of that
um I would say like look it's about
getting assembling your your tribe your
crew of sorts right so doing the short
films can help you find that that team
can also help you learn
and I don't think it's it's unwise to do
so I just think there's certain people
who like they're on their eighth or
tenth short now right
they've done the shorts they've won the
awards like they've gotten like you know
maybe even
uh you know some people who want to give
them some funding or whatever but
they're just scared in certain ways too
and the other part of it is like they
don't think that's enough money to do
their Vision well guess what there's a
cheaper version of your vision out there
I promise you this so don't get I mean
do the shorts find your tribe do all
those things right find the actors you
like working with that you know like you
you know Tarantino has his crew of
people he always works with and stuff
and you can find those people too
um you know at the same time that don't
you keep on doing too many shorts It's
indicative to me that you're you're
fearful something's holding you back you
should take the time and energy take
that year or two instead of doing any
shorts we're doing a feature and we're
going to talk to everybody like we're
going to shoot this as we have money so
we're gonna shoot this like four
different times you might need to keep
your hair cut over there you need to
keep that mustache or grow that mustache
back when we need you to
um but and don't gain any weight okay
don't get you lose some weight lose them
you know whatever it is so you can look
the same game you know spend the time
make the movie it puts you in a
different Club I promise you this but if
you need the time if you're a young
burgeoning filmmaker and you've never
done anything sure why not shoot like
two or three shorts but make each one
count like learn something from each one
just don't go shoot like one after the
other because it's just you know I feel
the art in my heart no no have a good
story let's win some awards this time
let's like let's submit to some
festivals let's get some like Rec you
know people to recognize you for your
talent because that's only going to help
you get money for the future let's say
that's an idea